so you mentioned that you and I might be
playing in the space of ideas but
there's two ways to play in this piece
of ideas both of which we're currently
engaging and so one is the communication
of that to other people it could be a
classroom full of students but it could
be a podcast it could be something
that's uh that's shown on YouTube and so
on or it could be just the act of
sitting alone and playing with ideas in
your head or maybe with a loved one
having a conversation that nobody gets
to see the experience of just sort of
looking up at the sky and wondering uh
different things maybe quoting some
philosophers from the past and playing
with those little ideas and that little
exchange is forgotten forever but you
got to experience it and maybe
we will I wonder if it localizes that
exchange of ideas for that with AI it'll
become less and less valuable to
communicate with a large group of people
that you will live life intimately and
and richly just with that Circle of meat
bags that you seem to love
so the first is even if you're alone in
a forest having this amazing thought
when you exit that Forest the baggage
that you carry has been shifted has been
altered by that thought
when I bike to work in the morning I
listen to books
and I'm alone no one else is there I'm
having that experience by myself and yet
in the evening when I speak with someone
an idea that was formed there could come
back
sometimes when I fall asleep I fall
asleep listening to a book and in the
morning I'll be full of ideas that I
never even process consciously I'll
process them unconsciously and they will
shape that baggage that I carry that
will then shape my interactions and
again affect ultimately all of humanity
in some Butterfly Effect minute kind of
way
so that's one aspect
the second aspect is
Gatherings so basically you and I are
having a conversation
which feels very private but we're
sharing with the world
and then later tonight you're coming
over and we're having a conversation
that will be very public with dozens of
other people but we will not share with
the world yeah
so in a way which one's more private the
one here or the one there here there's
just two of us but a lot of others
listening there a lot of people speaking
and thinking together and bouncing off
each other and maybe that will then
impact your millions of you know
audience
through your next conversation and
I think that's part of the beauty of
humanity the fact that no matter how
small how alone how broadcast
immediately or later on something is
still percolates through the human
psyche
human gatherings
all throughout human history there's
been gatherings
I wonder how those Gatherings have
impacted the direction of human
civilization just uh thinking of
in the early days of the Nazi party
it was a small collection of people
Gathering
and the uh the kernel of an idea in that
case an evil idea
uh gave birth to something that actually
had a transformative impact on all the
human civilization and then there's a
similar kind of gatherings that lead to
positive transformations